[Music]
do you find the time it takes earth to
spin around each day a little slow
love it how about we speed things up a
lot
what would happen to the length of our
day
what geographical and climate related
changes would occur
and at what point would life on earth
cease to exist
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was spinning at the
speed of light
the earth makes one full rotation on its
axis every 23 hours 56 minutes and 4.1
seconds
and it's not moving at the same speed
everywhere
the rotational speed varies depending on
your distance to the poles
if you're at the equator it moves the
fastest at a rate of
460 meters per second
at the north or south pole it's moving
the slowest
technically it's not moving at all this
rotation makes earth suitable for life
the diurnal cycle or the shifting
between day and night helps keep the
planet at a habitable temperature
earth's rotation is the driving force of
weather patterns
even tides are affected by the earth's
spin
so if we were to accelerate this
rotation would we completely destabilize
the climate
if you increased the rotational speed by
0.45 meters per second our days would be
shorter
but only by a minute and a half
you might not even notice the change i
don't know but even with this slight
increase sea levels would rise by
several centimeters or a few inches
yeah the water around the poles would
migrate toward the equator now if you
increased this acceleration to 45 meters
per second
then a single day would be about 22
hours
you'd start to feel confused almost like
jet lag
we'd also need to add a few more days to
the year
but for sea levels it would be a
dramatic change
the world's oceans at the equator would
rise as much as 9 to 20
meters places like new york venice and
mumbai would be submerged
millions of people would be displaced
now if we doubled the current rotation
speed to 920 meters per second disaster
would strike
water would cover everything except for
the highest mountains like kilimanjaro
or the highest summits of the andes
satellites orbiting the planet would be
out of sync as they need to orbit at a
speed that matches our rotation
this would disrupt communications
television broadcasting and military
operations
and you would notice some significant
weather changes
the air would be heavy with moisture
dense fog clouds and constant rain would
be the norm in regions near the equator
if you keep speeding things up
at some point you could fly off the
planet
that's because the centrifugal force of
the rotation would be enough to overcome
the gravity keeping you on the surface
this would happen at a speed of
7886 meters per second
and you would experience reverse rain
yeah droplets of water would move upward
in the atmosphere instead of falling now
if you pushed the speed to 11 000 meters
per second the earth's crust would begin
to flatten at the poles and bulge around
the equator enormous earthquakes would
rattle the planet there would be little
chance that anything on earth could
survive
but if you were to crank the velocity up
some more brace yourself
like to the speed of light things would
get wild
if the earth rotated at a speed of 299
792 kilometers per second that would be
652 000 times faster than today
the dimensions of the planet would
change
once a sphere the earth would contract
into a thin disk-like shape and so would
you along with every other object you
could finally say the earth is flat the
earth is flat and stationary rotating at
this extreme speed would distort time on
earth
it would slow down so much that it would
eventually stop you would freeze in time
so hopefully you'd be caught in a good
moment
earth could become a tiny black hole
that's because an object moving at the
speed of light has an infinite mass
yeah nothing would be making it out of
this situation alive
uh maybe we'd stand a better chance if
earth started spinning in the opposite
direction
but that's a story
for another
what if